your gift can be anything you can't look
at it as simply running jumping singing
and dancing failure means you've now
learned another valuable lesson that
pushes you one step closer to success
everything you see above ground that
blossoms and plants and grows and that's
beautiful it was on the ground one time
when people try to figure out how to
make a million dollars they have no idea
how daunting that is because do you know
how to make a million dollars you gonna
make it tomorrow if I had as many
followers as Kim Kardashian I probably
wouldn't even have to do this TV show
when you strike out on your goal you're
going to have to get ready for
flexibility your dream is free the
hustle is sold separately
I aim for stuff so big that the dream is
bigger than the fear and I want you to
take a look at this sign as they pull
the cord can you see this yeah I'm
looking at it he's an American comedian
TV host actor and author he's the host
of the Steve Harvey Morning Show Steve
Harvey Family Feud and little big shots
he's a three-time Daytime Emmy Award
winner he's Steve Harvey and here's my
take on his top ten rules her success
your gift can be anything you can't look
at it as simply running jumping singing
and dancing but I tell you one thing
your gift is the thing that you do the
absolute best with the least amount of
effort for me it was comedy so once you
identified then that's that's the
beginning of it but there's a lot of
work to do even after you identify your
gift you know you can believe you're
something all you want but if you don't
work towards it you just sitting there
it's gonna be empty value means you've
now learned another valuable lesson that
pushes you one step closer to success it
means go in another direction is not the
end all know people keep getting buried
on the fifth I bet you that you have
failed more times than anyone in this
room absolutely I promise you you have
I'm willing to bet that I have failed
more times than anyone in this room
because I have attempted so many things
that you have no idea what I've
attempted and failed
but I don't let the failures define it's
God pointing you in another direction
it's it's an N and it's clear about that
and you've got to be willing to go with
that being because that being in the
road is the only way success is not a
straight line it's not it's it's crooked
it's down in the valley is back up over
a mountain see I'm a seed I really am
I see but a seed has to be planted a
seed got to have dirt put on top of it
if you take a seed and throw it on the
concrete and walk off the Sun just burn
it up but guess what logically in my
mind it doesn't make sense that to grow
something you should dig a hole put it
down in there and cover it with dirt
logically that don't make no sense to me
but odo see dirt is necessary for growth
and development dirt builds character
dealt dealt gives you the push through
factor dirt makes you come with it when
you don't feel like coming with it no
more and you get dirt in a lot of
different ways all the other had dirt
fold on you dirt ain't always what you
want it's somebody talking about you
down on your job it's somebody accusing
you or something that you didn't do if
somebody telling you you ain't gonna
make it if somebody shared information
about you that ain't true got everybody
get dirt put on but see when you getting
put under that stress please know God is
always working Kurt Franklin song God is
always working so I smile because I know
he back there see that dirt builds
character in you when they talking about
you it teaches you to withstand it then
it gives you something to push through
so when you put the seed and you put the
dirt on it if you understand stress
stress really ain't just dirt stress see
they don't call it dirt when a planet
they call it soil because the soil has
nutrients in it
what the nutrients were people talking
about your dog and you lied on you back
by stealing from you talking about you
they're actually putting nutrients now
the see if they put a camera on the
ground you'd have seen the see sprout
open and start coming through the dirt
because the dirt is necessary so you
improve yourself everything you see
above ground that blossoms and plants
and grows and that's beautiful it was on
the ground one time all them potatoes
collard greens they was underground one
time then apple trees they was
underground one time so they had to
prove they sell so you want to be
successful well then you got to prove
yourself you got to push through the
dirt you got to come up through here
you've got to come out then you sprout
and then Bishop say then you become a
treat next thing you know you got fruit
so when people try to figure out how to
make a million dollars they have no idea
how daunting that is because if you know
how to make a million dollars you gonna
make it tomorrow but sis you can't
figure out how to a million dollar did
you go somewhere and sit down that's the
wrong approach if you apply your gift
your god-given gift that he gave you you
have millions already at your disposal
if you break it down it's by answering
these things a cinch for the 10 by 10
theory
what is it very simple you don't need a
million dollar do you need a ten dollar
idea you need something that you do your
gift that God gave you to make ten
dollars that's all you got to be a no
okay if it's cutting hair cutting
somebody's grass watching somebody's car
I don't care if it's a moment somebody
lawn I don't care if it's the driving
people today destinations I don't care
if it's babysitting I don't care if it's
baking cookies up high you have some
brain somebody have you have something
that you can do so well that someone
will give you ten dollars for it write
my paper for me do this for me somebody
give you ten dollars for once they give
you ten dollars all you got to do is
whatever you did to get that ten to a
ten more time
you know my friend had $100 you have
$1,100 simply because you took a $10
idea and you did it 10 times well guess
what if you take that $100 that you made
since you've done it 10 times and you do
it 10 more times I Got News for you my
friend
you now have $1,000 $1,000 you make
$1,000 guess what all you got to do you
got to multiply that effort again do
whatever you need to do a thousand
dollars do it two more times my friend
you now have ten thousand dollars you
got ten thousand dollars now imagine if
you was making an extra ten thousand a
month just imagine if you was making an
extra ten thousand dollars a month
that's 120 thousand dollars a year but I
Got News for you my friend whatever you
did whatever you did whatever it took to
make yourself ten thousand dollars
all you got to do is do it ten more
times two more times my friend
you now have 100 thousand dollars
I Got News for you now if you can make
$100,000 you're just a step away from
being a millionaire man because now you
have a few more people to help you out
that that you can do portions of what
you do so you can duplicate that effort
and one more time just one more time and
do it ten times man that sounds hard it
is hard but what else you got to do what
you gonna stop it two hundred thousand
all you got to do is duplicate your
efforts by ten you duplicate your
efforts by ten ten times 100,000 welcome
to the club my friends you are now a
millionaire congratulations you became a
millionaire with a $10 idea so stop
trying to stop bogging yourself down
trying to figure out how to make a
million do what you can do to make $10
and then do the ten by ten Theory
inch-by-inch anything since when you are
a person who is success minded you have
a wagon that you are pulling uphill
attached to this wagon is this very
thick rope you are shirtless you have a
rope on your back and you are pulling
this wagon uphill at all times you are
totally responsible for your wagon you
are the only one on rope now in order
for the wagon to go up the hill you have
to have people like-minded people people
on your staff employees people who you
partner with the thing of it is though
you are the only one responsible for the
pool what you have to be careful of is
as you pull this road up the rope up the
hill you have to make sure that
everybody that's on the wagon is doing
something to get the wagon up the hill
everybody's foot got to be hanging off
that wagon pushing somebody got to get
off the way I get it move rocks from
under the wheel it's an old wagon you
pull it but what happens along the way
and you got to be careful there are
people who will get on your wagon and
have no value get on your wagon and
become very very comfortable all of a
sudden they feet up off the ground they
just own the wag
right and you have them in your life as
as a mother everybody has you all got
somebody wagon their pulleys that's
doing nothing's got their feet up
seriously
sometimes your children they don't just
put their feet up now at a young age you
understand that but once they get to a
certain age you want film to help out
sometimes it's your business partner
sometimes the people you hire sometimes
the people in your other department
that's supposed to be helping with a
project and they just got their feet up
well what whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa you
are now making my haul on this rope more
difficult than it is you must now share
yourself with this dead weight if you
don't yo yo climb with your rope will be
it's agonizing one of my weak points in
my personal life is I don't like
technical stuff so even though I have to
be on Twitter and Instagram and Facebook
I don't care for that so guess what I
find somebody who loves to do that you
know I find somebody who has a strength
where I will have a weakness and I
partner with them all you're trying to
do is get to the goal
no one gets there by themselves
everybody needs help now when you know
what you got going for you be confident
not cocky managing your strengths
knowing what they are and don't let
nobody talk you out of it and that gets
you fight ready
you get fight ready like that you've got
to know you helps you develop your
skills all the while you're developing
your strengths it's not you just got to
keep developing the strength don't
everybody talk to you at the same time
you must work on improving your
weaknesses so I've had to in spite of
myself get on Instagram get on Twitter
get on Facebook I got to do the videos
whether I want to or not because the
world is moving to social media if I had
as many followers as Kim Kardashian I
probably wouldn't even have to do this
TV show Jennifer says life is what
happens when you're busy making plans
should my plan be solid or flexible once
I'm clear on what I want well it's a
combination of both
but you got to get tunnel vision to
reach your goal you have to put blinders
on and say I'm laser being focused on
this but know this the road to success
is always under construction so just
knowing when you strike out on your goal
you're going to have to get ready for
flexibility because it's gonna be
detours pitfalls stop signs men working
or delays detours going around that has
to be expected Terrell who's our floor
manager he was his first job was at
Magic Johnson see the hustle man
somebody said their wonderful side one
day it was like a sign that goes in
front of a house just for sale
it says the dream is free the hustle the
soul separate and that's so true man
you'd never see you can never give up
you don't ever know where God is just
waiting on you to pass the test but but
you have to stay with something and go
through the test to get to the end see
so you can't give if you quit there's no
way you'll ever know you have to keep
putting one foot in front of the other
even if you don't know what it Wayne
it's not your job to know the way it's
just a job to believe that's what people
mess up as people you you try to figure
it out show me the scripture that tells
you to figure it out where's that
scripture there's no scripture tells you
to figure it out it tells you to ask and
believe now what you got to do ask God
for something and believe it and now if
you got a fake when I worked your dad
you gotta be willing to hustle because
the hustle sold separately now
the dream for you dream all day long but
the hustle sold separately God will all
of us to do the gift that he put in us
now your gift might be attached to a job
some of y'all should have been in quit
your job and tried to business I did but
now you I've got these bills I can't
quit tell you what if you don't quit if
you do not quit they go fulfill your
dream you ain't ever gonna be happy
it ain't no way cuz you ain't living in
your dream you got to do it just take
the leap of faith what you're waiting on
God be a God who you want you a cup of
cuts and tears on you on the way once
you jump because when you jump just
notice right away the past she's not
gonna open right
you jump you're gonna hit the rock ages
are rocking on it but after a while it
opens but it ain't gonna open if you
don't jump then you can stay safe you
can stand on the cliff watching
everybody suing by and never jump keep
their parachute on your back tucked in a
pack be nice and say don't jump
but you won't watch a lot of people saw
and bad with a pass you know until you
jump you will never had a life that God
want you to head if you ain't gonna jump
man you've got to jump just jump wanted
to ask you how do you overcome the fears
and doubts I mean look the the fears and
doubts are a part of it can I be honest
with you everything I've ever done
started with a fear my walking out on
stage that starts with the fear when
Oprah came and got me for this lime
please I told us it or this is like a
stand-up appearance for me I'm back
there sweating I don't wanna talk to
nobody
I have to overcome fear all the time
when I wrote my book I was afraid when
they told me we wanted you to be a game
show host I've never done that
I was afraid when they said won't you do
a talk show I was afraid I have to
overcome fear all the time but the best
way for me to overcome fear is the dream
has to be bigger than the field that's
the only way you turn around and run at
it I just want something so great I aim
for stuff so big that the dream is
bigger than the fear look at it like
this man if you don't ever go for this
high it would it be better for you to
face your fear or just deal with the
fact that you just never gave it a shot
face it definitely see that's what the
dream and I saw you with you with your
tie on I know that makeup mirror that's
backstage somewhere in a dressing room
somebody's hiring guys like you is no
such thing as - oh I'm 57 if I went back
out there I get hired tomorrow as a
stand-up if you funny there's a market
place for you now look you gotta start
where you are right just turn we are now
behind me is a sign and I want you to
take a look at this sign as they pull
the cord can you see this yeah
looking at it here we go
[Applause]
like mr. Harvey I want to read the last
paragraph of the proclamation it says
now therefore I Mayor Frank G Jackson
the fifty-six mayor of the city of
Cleveland do hereby offer this
Proclamation in recognition of the Steve
Harvey day I invite all cleaners to join
me in congratulating mr. Harvey on his
success and commending him on his
contribution to the city of Cleveland
and the community one more time happy
birthday to Steve Harvey
[Applause]
yesterday I made my family mad but you
know what that look at that I learned
everything I know about survival on that
block right there with them dudes you
looking at right there
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Titian Stan asked me
to so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you are made of profile next leave
incomes below and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Steve's
top 10 rules impact you the most and why
leave in the comments I'll join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
whatever you think riches is that's your
definition there's a survey that says
riches and success is being happy while
all you have to do then is determine
what is it that makes you happy and
start down that path now to find true
success I believe that you've got to do
some work because it's not free
everybody would love to wake up and just
be happy and bubbly but it requires some
work so I want to share with you
something from my book chapter eleven
there is no self-made man now most of us
want to believe that we're independent
that if we set our minds to do something
simply it can get done well I got news
for you unless you look to others you
can work twice as hard to get half as
much
sometimes you need a partner in the deal
in order to aid you along the way there
is nothing wrong with asking for what
you want you know for a long time I used
to think that the path to success was
going at it alone because I was always
busy pride in myself or not asking for
help I was homeless I didn't want to ask
for help I lived in a car I didn't want
to ask for help and I almost missed out
I didn't realize how many people were
willing to have discussions with me
about success you know most people that
are successful if you ask them for help
they'll give it to you I'm talking about
advice principles solutions not money
see you what one thing you is not never
good I do don't walk up to a wealthy
person that just asks for money you know
many times they didn't got that but if
you're interested in learning how to
fish a lot of people that teach you how
to fish as opposed to giving you a fish
sandwich because they know if they give
you the fish sandwich you're gonna eat
it you're gonna have to come back a lot
of people have helped me along the way
Magic Johnson Oprah Winfrey the
president did I've had some
conversations with some people who have
it together and they've taught me many
things about succeeding that you might
think that requesting help is a huge-ass
but it's not people don't mind sharing
knowledge what is knowledge unless is
shared if you have knowledge but you
never shared how
no you got it and just remember there is
no shame in wanting something this whole
world is based on wanting something you
know don't sit up and listen to some
group you know won't and something is a
sin no it's not you got to want
something the scripture says a man
without a dream or vision shall perish
so the day you quit wanting something
you might as well push your chips up to
the window it's a wrap so lose the shame
and you'll have access to more power and
so here's the key that I wanted to tell
you about success is all about building
relationships it's not what you know
it's who you know some people might not
step up when you ask them for help they
might not but guess what the worst thing
can happen to you if somebody refuses
you you didn't have it anyway what are
you worrying about that for well they
might say no or they might turn me down
ask people you never know suppose they
say yes that could be the turning factor
but you know there are some principles
that will increase your chances of
getting a success know your worth don't
let nobody else determine it and don't
assume anything
people aren't mind reader's they don't
know what you think and don't assume
they know unless you ask with specifics
and then recognize that know is not a
rejection every time you hear no it
moves you one step closer to a yes
everybody can't say no now unless you
got a harebrained idea
and just remember that success is about
building a world that looks to wait you
want it to nobody else never be afraid
to reinvent yourself my career my entire
career is a study in reinvention you
know I started out as a comedian that
was it I never planned on hosting a
radio show hosting a game show or
hosting a daytime talk show I never did
writing books none of it making movies
none of it
reinvention happens when you diversify
your guilt there lies your greatest
secret for success
you've got to discover your gift and
when you discover it you got to soak it
you got to wring it out man you got to
diversify it most of us only have one
Talent but do you know that that's all
you need mine happens to be to take
information and immediately transfer it
into other kinds of platforms now when I
was younger I actually thought that I
could only do that with comedy but as
I've gotten older I discovered through
diversification that it was a little bit
more than that then I could also take
information immediately transfer it into
inspiration I could turn it into
motivation I can offer it as guidance so
now sitting on a talk show I actually
have something to talk about all the
failed marriages I got something to talk
about
to be at homeless I got something to
talk about being dead broke I got
something to talk about having bad
credit tax problems I got something to
talk about whatever hole you've been in
I'm just about drugged myself through it
but I came out of all of it because I
was not afraid to diversify my gift even
the book act like a lady think like a
man it was all about me diversifying
again okay I had taken two failed
marriages and I had taken the love for
my daughters and I combined those things
I taught my daughters what I knew about
men now little did I discover that I had
a little over 4 million daughters in
this country cousins and nieces and
stuff like that who needed that same
information and and that was a huge part
for me
to take that information and turn it
into a book that turned it into a mega
star movie - and it produced a lot of
things for me but it also helped a lot
of people one of the other tricks for
reinventing yourself is not letting your
background become a limitation if you
take that background that you're from
and never let it define you but allow it
to redefine you all that stuff works for
the good do you understand that you
needed everything that's happened to you
to happen to you in the exact order that
has happened in order for you to be the
person that you are today all that
failed and then didn't know that you
needed all of that so it's it's good to
be steeped in the traditions of your
gift but don't get stuck in them look if
your gift is bacon don't assume that
there's only one way to do it if you
bake bake but you can't just bake for
people you know bake for people you
don't know your musician let yourself
explore other types of music I got to
tell you example the roots who play on
Jimmy Fallon show
they steeped in hip-hop but they're also
great musicians so what they do is they
take all of that talent and now guess
what hip-hop jazz R&B classic pop rock
they didn't just get stuck on here but
I'm doing hip-hop that's it now they do
whatever LL Cool J hip-hop more on the
top actors on TV today Queen Latifah
hip-hop
big active right now you get it Jerry
Seinfeld nothing but a comedian on the
biggest actors on TV today remember you
can win if you're not afraid to reinvent
yourself stop getting stuck just go
ahead and give it a try you never know
you also need some outside perspective
if you listen to people that's close to
you that have your best interests I'd
you can use these outside observers to
gain knowledge to assess yourself and
when you reset reach out to get these
outside opinions be open keep your
emotions in check mark you can't say
that but just keep your emotions in
check now from now you're gonna have a
good feel about what your strengths and
weaknesses are and you can work on them
to build them